you buy a Happy Meal and on the side of
a cup and on the side of the fries I
want to say are double stickers and you
peel them off and sometimes it's a free
McFlurry sometimes it's free whatever
and then you can also combine these
together in order to build a Monopoly
board when McDonald's first released the
lottery it went absolutely wild they
were dropping at least hundreds of
thousands of dollars that people could
win with just one of these stickers they
left one dude that used to be part of an
advertising company in charge of this he
gets in with the mob and they've got a
sophisticated system it's people that
are unrelated cashing them in in
different states using different names
using different IDs but then when you
actually look at where all of the money
ends up coming back to it's within a
three mile radius of his home postcode
this guy gets away with it for ages and
ages and the way that he gets away with
it is he has McDonald's on the hook it
might not be McDonald's I think it's
technically the company that did the
competition on behalf of McDonald's
because they weren't following elements
of security correctly as well so he ends
up having something over them and then
he gets caught oh dude it's a really
really great story